صحيفه الواشنطن بوست نقلت عن مسؤولين
عسكريين وامني اسرائيليين قولهم ان
المكاسب العسكريه في غزه رغم اهميتها غير
كامله وقد تفقد بسبب الافتقار الى
استراتيجيه ما بعد الحرب واضافوا ان الجيش
الان اصبح ثابتا ومكلفا بالحفاظ على
سيطرته في المناطق الهادئه بدلا من محاوله
السيطره على مزيد من الاراضي ونقلت واشنطن
بوست عن مسؤول عسكري اسرائيلي ان شبكه
انفاق حماس اكثر اتساعا بكثير من تق
تقديرات الجيش الاسرائيلي السابقه حيث
تمتد لمسافه تزيد على 300 ميل في جنوب
القطاع وحده وقال انه من غير المرجح ان
يتم تفكيك شبكه انفاق حماس بكاملها مشيرا
الى ان خلايا حماس الصغيره المختبئه في
الانفاق وفي المباني المهدمه لا تزال تمثل
تهديدا فتاكا وقالت واشنطن بوست ان السؤال
المفتوح
والمربكة كيف ستعيد حماس ترميم نفسها
ونقلت عن مصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه ان
الوجود الامنيه طويل الامد في غزه كابوس
رفضه الكثيرون في المؤسسه الامنيه كما
نقلت عن مسؤول امني اسرائيلي سابق ان خطر
اعاده حماس تجميع مقاتليها سيظل حاضرا على
الدوام بدون جهد دولي منسق للحد من قوه
الحركه في غزه بعد
الحرب